la forma alterna de la derivada de la
función f en un número ha denotado por
efe prima de a está dado por esta
expresión y que está dado por un límite
verdad entonces la derivada en el punto
a es el límite cuando x tiende a de la
función f de bueno de la función
evaluada en x menos la función evaluada
en a todo eso entre x menos a y esto es
por supuesto suponiendo que el límite
existe más o menos en un dibujito
digamos si aquí tengo mis ejes y bueno
voy a intentar dibujarlo un poquito
mejor si ahí tengo yo mis ejes este es
el eje x el eje i y por aquí tengo una
función f esto es efe de x muy bien
entonces si yo tengo digamos vamos a
poner por aquí vamos a poner con rojo el
punto coma de fedea aquí está
así que este punto de aquí es el a
efe muy bien y ahora nos tomamos un x
cualquiera digamos que ande por aquí l x
aquí anda x más o menos queremos dar la
interpretación de esto aunque entonces
si nos tomamos ese x aquí tenemos el
punto x coma
fx muy bien entonces lo que nos está
diciendo este límite esencialmente es
nos está calculando la pendiente verdad
este numerador de aquí bueno aquí está
por ejemplo este es fx y este es x que
corresponden al punto verde lo que
corresponde al punto rojo es esto ahora
si nosotros queremos interpretar esta
diferencia que desde el numerador pues
esencialmente me está diciendo si a fx
le restó de fedea es más o menos esta
altura
a esta altura muy bien es esencialmente
el cambio en la dirección vertical ahora
la parte de acá abajo la parte de acá
abajo es x menos a entonces es esta
distancia le quitamos esta pequeña y lo
que nos queda es simplemente el cambio
en la dirección x o en la dirección
horizontal y esto no es otra cosa más
que la pendiente es la pendiente de que
de la recta que une estos dos puntos muy
bien ahí tenemos la recta que une esos
dos puntos y esta me calcula la
pendiente ahora si x tiende a lo que
estamos haciendo es que este x se
aproxime cada vez más
muy bien entonces lo que al final nos va
a quedar es la pendiente de la recta
tangente en este punto muy bien entonces
ahora dice el problema con la ayuda de
la forma alterna de la derivada darle
sentido al siguiente límite
identificando la función f y el número
muy bien entonces me está diciendo que
la derivada en 5 es igual al límite
cuando extiende a 5 de x al cubo menos
125 entre x menos 5 y simplemente hay
que identificar con lo que tenemos acá
arriba por ejemplo aquí me dice que el
punto donde está calculando la derivada
en este caso va a ser 5 y de hecho el 5
está r a correspondía al color rojo
entonces vamos a poner este con rojo muy
bien y de hecho también podemos ver que
fedea o bueno primero veamos quiénes fx
y fx me dice que es x al cubo esto es x
al cubo la función entonces
inmediatamente podemos decir que la
función es x al cubo y verificamos que
125 aquí estamos restando la función
evaluada en la que en este caso es 5
entonces efe de 5 en efecto va a ser 5
al cubo que es 125 todo coincide muy
bien aquí está por ejemplo la equis aquí
está a que 5
ya tenemos resuelto este detalle muy
bien entonces la derivada de la función
es la derivada de la función f x y la
función es x al cubo y el punto en el
cual estamos evaluando es en 5 muy bien
ahora solo para que quede todavía más
claro vamos a hacer un dibujo de que
estamos haciendo
digamos que aquí tenemos nuestros ejes
aunque no lo voy a hacer escala porque
ésta es una función bastante complicada
porque aquí en 125 aquí en 125 es el
valor que toma en 5 por ejemplo si aquí
ponemos 5 que claramente ya no está en
la misma escala pues entonces el punto
el punto por donde pasa la función y
está digamos más o menos por aquí muy
bien y como se ve la función x al cubo
pues más o menos se ve como algo que
pasa por aquí de forma tan gente que
quizás vamos a dibujarlo no tan
pronunciado más o menos así y sube y
luego de aquí va
complicado más o menos así se ve la
función x al cubo esto es igual a x al
cubo aquí por supuesto en este punto
rojo de arriba este es el punto 5 coma
lo que vale la función en 5 que son 125
muy bien y ahora si nosotros nos tomamos
cualquier punto x digamos este punto x
de aquí y consideramos el punto sobre la
gráfica es decir x coma x al cubo
entonces lo que está haciendo este
cociente es simplemente calcular la
pendiente de la recta secante es decir
la que pasa por estos dos puntos más o
menos algo así
más o menos y ahora si nosotros queremos
aproximar x cuando cuando se va
pareciendo cada vez más a 5 entonces la
pendiente de la recta tangente se va
pareciendo cada vez más a la pendiente
pero la pendiente de la recta african t
se parece cada vez más a la pendiente de
la recta tangente así que en el límite
la recta tangente se va a ver más o
menos algo así como la que pinte en
morado